- Hello, welcome.
We are so glad to have several of you,
a few hundred already, here today,
and really appreciate your time.
My name is Dave Herron.
I work on our team that supports teachers
and school districts at Khan
Academy, and I am joined today,
about two miles away, from
her home in San Francisco,
by my colleague Vicki Lang,
who is a learning scientist on our team.
So hello, Vicki.
And I'm also joined by my colleague Dan,
who helps lead our marketing team
from San Mateo, California.
Hi, Dan, and he will help actually, me,
surfacing some of your questions
all throughout the webinar,
and we'll leave the last
few minutes of the webinar
to answer as many as we can.
And so you'll see a question
tab on the GoToWebinar panel,
and if this is your first webinar with us,
then go ahead and take a look at that,
and at any moment when a
question pops into your head,
please put that in there
so that we can do our best
to answer as many as possible.
We're here to spend the
next 30 minutes or so
on the topic you should
be seeing on your screen.
Some of you may have found
yourself over the last
four or five, six weeks, maybe,
suddenly as homeschool
teachers, in addition to
all the other responsibilities
you're balancing.
We know it is a whole lot to juggle.
Here at Khan Academy, we
have created daily schedules
and now weekly math learning plans
to try to support you
as you support your kids
so that they can stay on
track as much as possible
in their math courses,
as well as other courses,
that they may be missing in school.
And so we're here to break
down these plans for you,
and I wanna thank, before we move on,
some of the key supporters who
have been providing support
to Khan Academy so that we could increase
the amount of support we're
providing throughout this time.
And you'll see those
names there on the screen.
Our main goal is to break
down the plans for you,
explain all the ins and outs
of these weekly math
learning plans, and again,
answer as many of your
questions as possible.
And before we move on,
I'm going to start a poll
to see how familiar this audience is
with the learning plans
that we're talking about.
So take the next few seconds,
once it pops up on your screen,
to tell us what best
represents your familiarity.
Are you I've never seen them before,
I'm here to learn, or I've seen them,
but I have not used them with my kids,
or finally, I have started
using them already with my kids.
We'll take about 10 more seconds.
If you haven't yet, fill in your vote.
Three, two, one, about two-thirds of you
have submitted your vote,
and here's where we're at.
Over half of you have never seen
these learning plans before, so thank you
for joining despite not
having that past familiarity.
We'll walk you through how to find them.
And then the others, about
a quarter, have seen them,
but haven't started using them,
and we do have some maybe
intermediate or advanced users
who have already started
using them with your kids.
We'll be really
appreciative of any feedback
or questions that you
have since you're already
started using them, and we have a survey
at the end of the webinar if
you wanna give us more advice
on how we can improve
them and move forward.
So given that over half of you
have never seen them before,
let's start with a pretty basic question.
I'll take this one, Vicki.
How do I even find the
learning plans to begin with?
If you go to our website
at khanacademy.org,
on the very home page, which
you should see an example of
on the screen now, there will
be a blue banner at the top.
That links you to some of our
remote learning resources.
And if you click that
link, you'll be brought
to that page that's shown on
the right side of the screen,
where one of the main options
are the weekly learning plans.
That will give you access
to all of the learning plans
that we've created so far.
We have them at many different
grade levels for math,
and we recently published
a high school biology
learning plan as well.
They are all in a format
that's very easy to print
if you do have a printer
accessible for you.
We know the learning plans
for kids are often helpful
to have in print form,
and so when you open it,
you may notice the
formatting looks different
than the regular Word document,
but that makes it easy
if you press control-P
or whatever the shortcut is
on your computer to print those out.
You might be multi-tasking right now
and following those steps to
access the learning plans,
and just those two other quick reminders.
I should've mentioned this
right at the beginning,
but there is a copy of these slides
available to download as
a PDF within the browser
that you have available, and then second,
we're recording the webinar,
and we'll send you a copy
of the recording soon after,
within a few hours after the conclusion.
Let's move on, though.
Who are the plans for?
What's the big goal or idea
behind these plans, Vicki?
- Well, as you said, they're for students
from 3rd grade through high
school for mathematics,
and then we also have one
for high school biology,
and they're really for
providing a clear goal
for what to work on week to week.
We know that it's great
to set a large goal
of being ready for next year
when school starts again,
and it can also be really
helpful in reaching that goal
to break it down into smaller steps.
We're breaking that goal down
into week-by-week-by-week
steps to get you ready,
or your child ready for next year.
On the next slide we can
see that the real audience
for this is folks who's districts maybe
have not provided enough support,
or you're looking for
something a little bit beyond
what your district has provided for you.
This is an overwhelming
time for school districts.
What they've been able to
provide has really varied,
and we wanna make sure that everybody
has access to a plan that they can use
to make sure that your kiddos
are ready for school next year.
- Perfect.
And as you mentioned,
these are far more specific
than the daily schedules
that we've put up.
I know we're receiving
this question already
in the chat room that
think of a daily schedule,
saying, maybe at this time per day,
you can work on this course,
if you're in 6th grade.
The weekly learning plan is
gonna get way more specific
on what unit and what
the actual goal could be
to complete by the end of it.
So let's talk about that.
What would you need to know
about the learning plans
to just even get started on
that first day with your kids?
- Well, if we look at a
sample, and we can look
at that 6th grade sample learning plan,
and I'll just show you
how it's structured there.
At the beginning, there's
gonna be some instructions
about how to use it, as well as,
you can see it says click
here for explainer video.
That's a short video where Sal talks more
about what to do with it.
And then there's some instructions here
about how you're going
to get your kids started.
Let's, for example, talk about a kiddo
who was supposed to be
finishing 6th grade right now,
will be entering 7th grade next year.
They've already learned probably
a lot of the 6th grade content,
so this is gonna explain
to have them start with
the course challenge
to earn credit for the things
that they already know,
and Dave will talk more
about that in a few minutes,
about how that mastery system works,
and the course challenges works,
but they're gonna get credit for
what they already know
by taking a pre-test.
And then they're going to, in the system,
have a to-do list of work that
they haven't mastered yet,
and that's gonna map onto this table here.
So what you're seeing in this table
is the 20-week version
of finishing 6th grade,
and the 20 weeks will take
you right up to August
to when 7th grade would begin.
And in this table, you'll
see that each row is a week
with an end date on Friday,
and then the color changes represent
a different unit of
instruction that's starting.
So for example, in this
one, in the first week
that student would take
that course challenge
to pre-test out of some of the content.
Then they would begin the ratios, rates,
and percentages unit,
and they would be aiming
to get about 600 points
that week in that unit.
The next week they would
continue work on that unit.
It's a pretty big unit.
They would aim to get to 1200 points.
That's another 600 points
for a total of 1200.
The following week, they
would aim to get to 1900,
and they would move on to the next course,
or to the next unit, I mean.
You're going to wanna decide
between the 20-week and
the 12-week options.
If you would keep scrolling down here,
you would see that
there's a 12-week option
that has you finished by the end of June.
And that just depends on how
much time you wanna invest.
You're gonna be able to fit
in a little bit more content
if you're with the 20-week option,
but we wanted to make sure
that if you wanna spend
only a shorter amount
of time and get to maybe
the time when the school year
would typically have ended,
that you're able to hit
all the really high points,
so that's what the 12-week one does.
And then if you keep
scrolling, you'll notice
there's another pair of tables,
and these are for a
foundational learning plan.
So those first two
tables tell a 6th grader
how to finish 6th grade.
The second pair of tables give you a plan
for our arithmetic class,
which is a foundational
skills class that supports 6th grade.
So if you have even more time
that you wanna invest in 6th grade,
or if your student is
struggling a little bit
with 6th grade, you
might have them also work
on this arithmetic course to build
some of those foundational
skills to support it.
And that's kind of what
you need to know there,
and then if we look here, we can see that
the most important time in
getting these learning plans
off the ground, or really,
in getting anything off
the ground with a kid
is the first two weeks,
the beginning of it,
where you wanna really
establish your routine
and get into a pattern with it.
And you can, things that
can help you with that
are making the plan physical.
If you do have a printer, print it.
If you don't have a printer, sketch it out
on a piece of paper.
Make it a place where they
can write and interact with
and really see on the
refrigerator or somewhere,
and making it a clear habit,
where there's a routine to it.
First, I'm gonna check my goals.
Then I'm gonna open and do some work.
Then I'm gonna record
my progress every day,
at the same time every day, maybe.
And with that, let's
see if Dave can tell us
a little bit more about
the mastery system,
'cause those tables really are grounded
in getting to about 70%
mastery on each of those units,
so we need to understand
what those points are
and how you get mastery
and how that would work.
- Absolutely, so as Vicki just showed,
there are references to different
point goals for learners
all throughout these learning plans.
And we know that it is
motivating to have a clear goal,
but it's also, I'm sure, helpful for you
as the parent or adult
to just be able to know
how those points are maybe calculated
and how to encourage your
kids to achieve those goals.
Let me show you a few screens.
This on the screen right
now is our 3rd grade plan.
This would be 3rd grade common core,
and on the left-hand column
are all the different units
in our 3rd grade math course.
And on the right-hand
side are all the points
available for each unit.
Every unit has a certain number of skills,
and every skill is a hundred points.
In the unit at the top,
maybe it's worth 800 points.
It's got eight different skills in it.
Those points are really important
for understanding the learning plans,
because all of the goals
reference unit mastery points.
The other thing I wanna
mention is Vicki alluded
to the course challenge.
If we were talking maybe in September
or near the start of a school year,
then a course challenge may not be
the first step for a student
if they're just getting
started on third grade.
But considering that it's springtime
and that your kids have
already learned a lot
of math this year, the
course challenge could be
a great way for them to quickly place out
of some of the skills that
they're already confident in.
So I would guide your kid to
click on the course challenge
as the first step, and
it will scroll them down
to the very end, actually,
and they'll get started
on that mixed review of
all the different skills
from throughout the year.
Just remember to remind
them that it's totally okay
if you don't know these answers,
'cause they'll include
some from the later units
that they may not have learned yet.
I also wanna show a brief
video that goes over
some of the other learning
experiences for students
so that I can explain a bit
about what you might be
seeing in the next few days.
Here I'm, as a learner,
clicking on that blue button
just a minute to start in on a lesson.
Here we're in addition and
subtraction within 100,
and there's gonna be a
bunch of learning resources,
our videos and articles,
and then there's gonna
be practice resources.
So I'm clicking on that
first practice problem set.
The practice problems,
some of them are gonna be
only four problems, some seven.
The longest might be 14 if it's like
a lot of procedural fluency.
And if I'm stuck on a
problem, what I just did is
I clicked on a video.
It was listed right
there, because it's really
closely aligned to the
practice that I'm doing.
If I'm done watching the video,
and now I know how to do
this problem of 92 plus 3,
then I can answer it, 95.
If I'm still not sure, I could get a hint.
And the hint is gonna
mark the problem wrong,
'cause it gives away the answer,
but encourage your kids to take hints.
When you look at the research,
the kids that take more hints,
even though they're getting
the initial problem wrong,
they end up making
faster progress over all.
I'm getting the questions right.
I'm getting instant feedback on this.
You might see the little
dots at the bottom
of the screen turning green,
so I've got a few more to go,
and if I do get to a 70% or higher,
then I'm gonna get points.
In this case, I'll get half
the points for that scale, 50,
so that's contributing to that
goal in the learning plan.
And I'm just about to finish
with the last problem,
and because I'm about to ace,
I think, this problem set
and get 100%, I'm gonna get
almost all the points for this scale.
So there should be some confetti
that rains down from the ceiling.
I just received 80 points.
Not quite a hundred, because
there's just one practice set,
and I haven't shown that
I still understand it
when it's mixed in with a
whole bunch of other concepts.
But I'm on my way towards
my goal for that week.
So if I go back to the unit overall,
then I'll see here in the top left corner,
I have now a total of 240 points.
So I know that was brief,
but that's kind of the
three-minute version
of our mastery system.
I think it's closely related to a question
we've already been hearing a lot,
how do I know if my kids are on track?
We do have parent accounts
that you can create on Khan Academy.
When we designed those parent accounts,
it was in a pre-covid world,
where we did not expect parents
to be homeschooling en masse,
and so the amount of detail
you'll find on there will be helpful
for getting an overview of how much time
your kids are spending and what
they've worked on recently,
but it's not gonna give
the detailed points
that you might need to tell
if they're on track for the learning plan.
Instead, what we recommend
is just having your kid
maybe once every few
days, maybe once a week,
whatever might work for you,
showing you their screen and
talking about how it's going,
and then you can look
at the points together
and turn it into a conversation of sorts.
Here again, on the right-hand,
I'll see the point values
for each unit, and that,
if I'm just to sort of
do a crosswalk for the learning plan,
then on the screen, you'll
see intro to multiplication.
I currently have 660 points.
So I've written that in there in pink,
into the second week of the learning plan.
I'm so close, but good news,
in one-digit multiplication,
I have 1,050 points, so
I've exceeded my goal.
The last one that I wanna talk over is
how you might help your
kids when you are stuck.
I taught 9th grade algebra one
for most of my teaching
career, and even though
I was a math teacher, if
I was asked by someone
more of a 4th grade level on
how to break down a skill,
it would be tough,
because it's hard to know
how to teach something at that level,
given what they understand currently.
So don't feel the pressure that
you have to be the teacher.
Instead, if they come to
you and they're stuck,
and they're saying one
topic's really confusing,
one strategy we recommend is just to watch
one of our videos with them
to see how you might
go about explaining it.
Chances are, after that
video, you will understand it
quite a bit better than your own kid,
and that might help you,
then, coach them a bit
on the next few problems.
If they seem just stuck
on one specific problem,
again, we recommend they
take a look at the hints.
They'll have multiple hints
available for each problem,
so they can get just the
first bit of the solution,
and maybe then, they'll have enough
of what they need to
finish out the problem.
Or they can click all the
way through to the answer.
But there is another scenario
where you might anticipate
just high levels of frustration.
Maybe your kid gets a lot of math anxiety,
or maybe they just have,
are already proving
to have a tough time as
they try to transition
to this really difficult
learning environment
of learning from home.
If you think that they are gonna have
some of that general frustration,
you'll see on the screen a
list of our different courses.
You might decide that you're
gonna start a level earlier,
build their confidence,
and as Vicki mentioned,
these plans are designed from
3rd grade to algebra two.
If your kids are more at a kindergarten,
1st, 2nd grade enrollment, or math level,
you might consider also checking out
some of the math resources
from Khan Academy Kids.
Back to you, Vicki.
- Unmuting.
How do we keep our kids motivated
to follow through with
these plans week-to-week?
Well, motivation for kids,
or for anybody, really,
is about value, what value are you finding
in the activity that you're doing?
We're not motivated to do things
that we don't think are valuable.
It also can be about agency.
We're sometimes not motivated to do things
that we feel like we
don't have a choice about,
so the key here, really, is to think about
what do your kids value?
What's gonna make it interesting
and exciting for them?
And what's gonna make them feel like
they have some choice and some ownership
over the work that they're doing?
On this slide, there's a
couple of suggestions here.
You could take on a challenge
in parallel with them,
so that the value comes
in spending time together
with a parent who is
also modeling learning.
You can use a simple reward system.
You can give them some choices about
when in the day they work on it,
but for a full webinar on
motivation for your kiddos
during this crisis time, we're gonna have
a full webinar on that
next Wednesday, April 29th.
We also are going to have
a webinar on motivating
and managing multiple kiddos
on different schedules on May 4th,
and we had a webinar a few
weeks ago on structuring,
it was called Structuring the Day
for Kids Two Through Seven,
because we did it with Khan Kids,
but what's really communicated
there is structure
and choice and connection and
keeping your kids motivated
and kind of bought into learning
by how you might schedule
some choice into their day.
And so there are some other
resources there for you.
But next Wednesday, motivation.
And then I think a big question here
with these learning plans
for me if I was a parent,
I am a parent right now, but
if I was using this at home,
would be that the first
week has already passed
in the learning plans, or
maybe this doesn't work
for my kiddo in some other way
in the way that it's structured.
How can I adapt it to meet
the needs of my own child?
You might need to a different
number of weeks, for example.
You might need to start
from an earlier grade
in order to build
confidence if you anticipate
that your kiddo is going to struggle.
You might wanna revise the goal each week,
especially if your child
earns a lot of points
on that course challenge up front.
The specific numbers that are week-by-week
and those goals might not make sense,
or your child might find
that they get to a week
where they've already
earned most of the points
in that unit from the course challenge,
and so maybe they can work
a little bit ahead to the next week.
We really want you to take
what's here as just inspiration
to be able to design a
plan that's going to work
for your specific child and
your specific situation.
Given that the first couple
of weeks have already passed
that are in the learning plan,
you might do something
like use the 12-week plan,
but start it now, instead of
starting it three weeks ago,
and it'll take you maybe into July.
But really, we want you to just figure out
a way to use this idea to build a plan
with small goals for your
child that will work for you.
And with that, I think we're
going to take some questions.
I'm already seeing lots of
great questions in the dock.
And I'll turn it over to Dan.
- Hi, everyone.
Dave, I wasn't sure if
you were gonna have a poll
before we jump into the questions?
- Oh, the poll, actually, we're gonna put
as part of a survey
right after the webinar
on actually your advice
on how we might name these learning plans.
If learning plan isn't the best thing,
we'll get your thoughts on that after.
- Perfect, well, thanks, Dave and Vicki.
Hi, everyone, I'm Dan.
I'll be moderating the live
QA portion of this session.
Two things to do before we
move into the question portion.
As Dave mentioned earlier,
please download the presentation
in the handout section,
and a recording of this,
as well as the handout,
will be emailed to those who registered,
and we'll post a recording
after this as well.
And the recording and the
document covers everything
from the learning plans, what they're for,
some of the recommendations,
as well as links to other
resources that we have available.
And then the second thing
we wanna ask of you all
is if you have any questions,
please add them now.
I know there's already a
lot of really good questions
in the question box, and I'll facilitate,
and Vicki and Dave will do the hard work
of actually answering the questions.
We already have a couple, and Vicki,
this one's probably more
appropriate for you.
Ganesh asks, based on what
Sal states today on Axios.
Sal was on Axios.
Understanding that kids
potentially going through
a five- to six-months learning loss,
and forgetting another six months' worth
of potential learning, kids may end up
being behind a complete year,
what are the practical steps
we can do to bridge the gap?
And actually, that's why we created
these learning plans in the first place.
So, Vicki?
- Yeah, this just, my heart hurts so much
when I think about this.
And I know districts
are working really hard
to figure out what they're
gonna do in the fall
to make sure that kids
aren't falling behind.
what you can do as the
grown-up in the meantime
is to keep your kid
practicing in gentle ways.
Don't push math all the time
in a way that makes them go,
"no, I don't want to."
But just gently reminding them that math
is part of their life,
helping them do a little
bit of math every day.
With my daughter, my daughter is six,
and we have a lot of
mathematical conversations.
When I'm doing something in the kitchen,
or when we're picking up her
toys, we count they toys.
We'll talk about math as
we're walking to the park.
We'll maybe estimate, does that bush have,
do you think it has more than 10 flowers
or less than 10 flowers?
And just trying to bring in casual ways
of talking about math throughout the day
in natural ways to your child,
and then if you can help them,
if they are willing to engage
with some online math learning,
like what we're providing
at Khan Academy, I think that's
really, really beneficial
to really keep them moving forward
with those on grade level skills.
But continue really just bringing math in.
- Perfect, and Dave, we
have a lot of questions
around standards alignment.
So from Cheryl, she's asking,
thank you for doing this.
Are the lessons geared toward states
with high math achievements,
such as Massachusetts or
others such as California?
And Jeanne asks a similar question.
Are these based on
particular states' standards?
- Yeah, great question.
The 3rd through 8th grade,
and then the high school curations,
those are gonna be common core curations.
The rigor of the questions
should be aligned
with many of the states' summative exams,
but you know, be the judge of that
as you take a look yourself,
and definitely consider
combining the resources
we have with other
things that the district
may be providing, other resources,
especially some of the
open-ended responses
that they might be getting
good practice on from their district.
- Perfect.
Vicki, we're getting a lot of questions
centered around how much
time a student will need
for each of these units.
So from Cindy asks, how much
time approximately per day
or per week are the schedules based on?
And Lisa asked, for
high school algebra one,
roughly how much time should
a student dedicate to this
to complete everything in the 20 weeks?
- That's a great question.
We designed them with the assumption
that your student might spend
a similar amount of time
to what they would spend in school,
so about 45 minutes to an
hour a day, five days a week
for that amount of time.
And the amount of time that
it's gonna really require them
to work through all the
work is gonna depend a lot
on how much they already remember
and test out of in the course challenge.
Some students may move much more quickly.
Some students may take a little more time.
It also may vary week to week depending
on how much they remember
in that particular unit,
but that's the basic recommendation.
- And kinda to piggyback off of that,
Stephanie asks how do
we know whether to use
the 12-week or the 20-week versions?
- I mean, that's really just up to you
and how much time you wanna invest
and whether you want
your child to continue
to practice math all the way
up until school starts again
in the fall or only through when
the regular school year might've ended.
You also might be deciding
between the regular
or on grade level learning plan
and the foundational learning plan.
And our thought is you might
do both at the same time.
You might also choose the foundational one
if your child is struggling
a little bit more in math,
or for specific targeted
topics, you might dip into that
to support some learning
that they're doing
in the regular grade level.
- And Stephanie's also
asking can she switch
from one to the other, and
I think the answer to that
is absolutely, test it out
and see what's most comfortable
and appropriate for you.
- Yeah.
- Dave, Elaine asks my 7th
grader uses Khan Academy
for math all the time.
How is this different?
- Well, the content should be similar.
The student experience
on getting mastery points
looks similar, as well,
but two things might
feel different for them.
One would be having a really clear goal,
and second might be the
extra involvement from you,
and those, I think, can
make a really big difference
with the way they engage with math.
But again, the actual content
and the mastery learning plans, or system,
is the same as in regular school year.
- And a little bit related to that, Dave,
Angela's asking if my child's
already doing Khan Academy
with his class, would
you still recommend him
doing the learning plan?
- I would recommend having
a conversation with them
and just seeing how they're feeling
about clarity on what
they should be working on.
If the answer comes back
a little tepid of like,
oh, we're not really
receiving much to work on,
because it is pretty
difficult for many districts
to just get enough learning
resources out there
in a short amount of time, then
this could supplement that.
But if they seem to
already have a full plate
of math practice coming from
their teacher and district,
then that might be a signal
that these learning plans
aren't necessary at this time.
- And, Vicki, we have a question.
We talked about grade level
and foundational things,
but there's a question,
where would you start
if your child's working
well above grade level?
- Yeah, I would start
with the course challenge
for the next grade level
or the course challenge
for this grade level.
That's a really good way for
your child to very quickly,
in just about 30 or 45 minutes,
get credit for the things
that they already know
and make sure that they
don't create any gaps
in things that they don't know.
But that's a great way to
kind of accelerate progress.
- Dave, we're getting
quite a few questions
on how do I track my kid's progress?
How should I think about it?
So, Angela Degotti asks, how do you see
how your child's doing in these skills?
- Yeah, so we sort of touched
on this within the webinar,
that the data available
on the parent dashboards
is probably not gonna be as
detailed as you're looking for,
since it was not created
with the homeschool mentality in mind.
That being said, you have two options.
First option is you could actually
create a teacher account
and enroll your kid
as your own student, and then
you will get detailed data,
and there's a lot of resources
on our site for the teacher data reports.
Or you could just have
them show you their screen
and have a conversation about it,
and that's our primary recommendation,
'cause it doesn't require you to know
all the ins and outs
of our teacher reports.
- And I think we have time
for one more question,
and Vicki, this one will be for you.
What's the difference between
the super ultra strong foundation plan
versus the super fun plan,
and then related to that,
is the 20-week just more
content, or is it the same,
but just spread out over a
different number of weeks?
- Yeah, the difference between the first,
I can't remember how we structured them,
or what we called them, whether
super fun or super great,
but the first learning
plan, the grade level,
3rd grade course, 6th grade course,
is just the grade level
content that your student
would've gotten at school this year.
It's the content from the entire grade,
not starting now, but the entire grade
in that grade level course.
The foundational one, the
one that says foundational
and the name of it, is a related course,
like early math, arithmetic,
that has more basic skills
that probably have that grade level skill,
but also stretch back a couple grades
to bring in some core
skills to really build
a strong foundation of earlier mathematics
and math fundamentals, so
that's the difference there.
I would say try to do both,
or lean in to the grade level one,
unless you're child's struggling,
and then lean in to the foundational one.
And the difference
between 20 and 12 weeks,
they're both the whole course.
In the 12-week, we pulled
out some of the units
that are a little bit less critical.
They're still, all math is important,
but maybe the less critical
for that grade level,
and put them as optional at the end.
So the 12 weeks just really breaks up
the most important key
skills from that grade,
and then it says, if you have extra time,
here's the other units that
you're gonna wanna work on.
Whereas the 20 week just
embeds the whole thing
in the order you would normally do it.
- Perfect, so I think we're at time.
Thank you, Dave, and thank you, Vicki,
for sharing your expertise.
And we wanted to thank
all of you, our audience,
for taking the time out of
your busy afternoons to be with us.
We know you're extremely
busy and we appreciate you
investing your time in this session.
If you missed something or
you wanna go back and play,
replay something, we know
this is a lot to cover
in a short period of time, this recording,
it will post it tomorrow.
It'll be made available
for those who registered.
It'll automatically be
sent to you in an email,
along with the presentation.
And we do have quite a few
other resources available
at khanacademy.org, so if you go there,
there's gonna be a blue ribbon at the top
speaking specifically to remote learning,
so you could always check that out.
We're making updates quite
frequently, every day, in fact.
So you can always go to khanacademy.org.
And then before we sign
off, we wanna ask you
to do us one more favor,
and please take the poll
that pops up at the very
end of this webinar,
and let us know two things.
First, how could we make future iterations
of this session even better for you all?
And then what kind of sessions
would you like to see next?
We've been asking this at
the end of each webinar,
and it's helping us plan
what's most useful for you all.
Please be sure to do that,
and then Dave mentioned the poll,
in terms of actually how to name these
in a way that resonates with you all.
So please fill that out for us.
And in closing, we know you're juggling
a lot as parents right now.
This is uncharted territory,
you're asking to be a parent
as well as a teacher, and we
wanna be here to support you.
And one more thing is just we want,
we here at Khan Academy want to remind you
to be kind to yourselves.
These schedules may appear to be a lot.
They're really recommendations.
Use them in a way that you feel
like it's most appropriate,
and don't feel pressured
to complete all 20 weeks.
You wanna try to get
through as much as you can
in a way that feels right for you.
And from all of us at Khan
Academy, thanks again,
and thanks for joining us, and goodbye.